what is up everybody it's annamac here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest
tear jerking events in the boku no hero
story
including the extremely emotional
confrontation between the new
dark avenger deku and his former
classmates from class
1a is deku going to continue slowly
killing himself
as he tries to do everything and save
everyone on his own
or is he finally going to accept the
fact that he cannot survive
without the help of his friends let's
get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going do me a favor and leave a quick
like and comment it's a totally free way
to support this channel
with that youtube algorithm and if
you're new to anime opera
or maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet do me a favor and
make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
finally this video will contain boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned
at the end of the previous chapter a
broken and exhausted deku was narrowly
saved by bakugo from being dog-piled to
death
bakugo took down the villain known as
dictator who was controlling a bunch of
innocent civilians and forcing them to
attack
a severely outnumbered deku as i
mentioned in my previous video
the villain known as dictator had
literally the perfect quirk for fighting
someone like deku his quirk allowed him
to take
control of a bunch of innocent civilians
and force them to do his bidding
and since these were all innocent
everyday people who were being forced to
attack
deku against their will deku couldn't
fight back
against them he didn't want to hurt
anyone who's innocent and didn't do
anything wrong
so deck was basically helpless in the
face of so many people swarming him
while he was already
in a completely exhausted state luckily
for deku
bakugo showed up just in the nick of
time and he took the villain out before
deku was
stomped to death but this situation
really exposed
deku's greatest weakness deku expects
too much from himself
he wants to do everything on his own
without putting anyone else in danger he
wants to save everyone
no matter the cost to his own body he
refuses to take a break while there are
innocent people out there who might need
his help
and so deku is constantly over exerting
and overextending himself
which is putting his own life at serious
risk the latest chapter begins with a
flashback that explains how
bakugou came to be in the right place at
the right time to save dekku in the
previous chapter
just a few days after deku first left
the ua
the class 1a students were not happy
about his decision
so they called a meeting inside their
dorm to discuss what their next step
should be right from the get-go the
class 1a student suspected that
deku was working together with the top 3
pro heroes
but they couldn't confirm this because
all those heroes refused to tell them
anything
based on how sketchy the top 3 heroes
were acting and based on
all might's behavior as well bakug and
the others concluded that
deku must be working with all might
endeavour hawks
and best genius behind the scenes even
though the media was reporting that only
the top three heroes had teamed up
the students suspected that they were
all working together with deku and
almight
so the students decided to dig deeper
and eventually they got pushy with
principal nezu in order to get the truth
the students convinced nezu to summon
endeavor to the school
and when he arrived endero was cornered
by the class 1a students
the students demanded to know the truth
about their friend and classmate deku
and todoroki even pulls the father-son
card on
endeavor because todoroki knows his
father so well
he is able to determine from endeavour's
facial expression that the top 3 heroes
are indeed secretly working with deku
and all might
and that's when bakugo steps in and
issues a warning
to endeavour the heroes do not know deku
as well as his friends do
deku is the type of person who always
sacrifices himself
for the sake of others even when he is
seriously injured
exhausted and on the verge of death deku
will always say that he's okay and that
he can keep
going in that way deku is very similar
to all might
and if they allow deku to keep doing
things his way he will probably get
himself
killed bakugou knows that if they want
to keep deku
safe they have to keep up with him and
watch over him
if they let deku do everything on his
own in his own way
he's almost certainly going to push
himself too far and then he won't be
able to help anyone
anymore if deku dies or gets seriously
injured
then how is he going to become a great
hero how is he going to save all of
those people who need
his help we all know that deku's
motivations are pure
he just really wants to help people but
he is too
short-sighted even if he ends up helping
more people
in the short term by risking his life
over and over again
at this rate he won't be able to help
anyone in the long term because he's
gonna get himself killed
endeavour seems to understand where the
students are coming from
because he ends up giving them a gps
tracker that will allow them to keep
tabs on
deku that is how bakugou was able to
find deku and save him from dictator
in that crucial moment bakugou and the
other class
1a students have been watching out for
deku from a distance
and when they saw that he had finally
reached his limit his classmates decided
to
act now that we've seen this flashback
it makes the moment in which bakugou
shows up to help deku
even more wholesome because we now know
that the class 1a students have been
watching over deku for some time
and it's not just bakugo who came here
to help deku
all of class 1a is here and they
immediately start helping all the
innocent civilians who were caught up in
the clutches of dictator
the exhausted deku asks his former
classmates
why they are here and ochako says that
it's because they were worried about him
i actually love dochaku in this chapter
but i'll talk about her a little bit
later
deku tries to tell all the class 1a
students that he's ok
and they should just stay away from him
since he knows that he is the main
target for the villains
deku doesn't want his friends anywhere
near him he doesn't want
anyone to get hurt because of him so he
tells them that he can't
look back he has to keep moving and they
all need to stay
out of his way but deku's classmates
refuse to back off
in the final panel of the chapter we see
bakugou
ida and ochako standing their ground and
refusing to get
out of deku's way and that is how the
chapter ends
with what looks like a looming
confrontation between
deku and his classmates but will deku
really try to fight his friends in order
to get them to back off
definitely not i just can't see that
happening deku would never seriously
fight someone like ochako and frankly he
wouldn't seriously fight
any of his classmates now deku might try
to get away from them
but with how injured and exhausted he
currently is there is no way that he
will be able to
outrun 19 people who are determined to
keep him there
although you never know he might unlock
the last quirk and it ends up being a
speed quirk or a teleportation quirk or
something but i just don't see him being
able to get away
in his current condition so it looks
like deku is finally going to learn
an extremely important lesson no matter
how strong he is
no matter how dedicated he is and no
matter how hard he pushes himself
in the end he simply cannot do
everything on his own
he has to accept the help of others
including the help
of his classmates that is the safest
and most effective way to save as many
innocent people
as possible i mean sure yes if the other
class
1a students stay with deku there is a
risk that some of them might get hurt
at some point in the future some of them
might even die
at the hands of one of the villains who
are targeting deku but that is the harsh
reality of being a hero
and since deku continues to be the best
chance that the heroes have of defeating
the villains
since deku has pretty much become the
symbol of hope for everyone
deku's classmates cannot allow him to
get himself killed as he almost did just
now
at the hands of dictator deku is too
important to them
as individuals and also to the hero
society as a whole and i think it's
about time for deku to realize that
personally i think that deku was deeply
traumatized by the events in jakku
and also by the chaos that erupted
across japan after all for one's prison
break
deku saw so many people dying and
suffering
and he felt terrible about not being
able to help them
so because he doesn't want his friends
and loved ones to have to go through
that kind of suffering
he is trying to protect them and take
all the responsibility for defeating the
villains
on himself however deku needs to look at
the current situation realistically
we are not talking about petty criminals
or minor villains here
we're talking about the villain
mastermind all for one and his minions
we are talking about the monster that is
awakened shigaraki
and we are talking about who knows how
many other overpowered villains who
escaped tartarus
and are now stalking the streets of
japan no matter how hard
deku tries he cannot defeat all of those
enemies
on his own all might tried to do
everything he could
on his own to save everyone and be the
symbol of peace and that worked well
while all might was the strongest hero
and in his prime but as we know after
all might retired
the society that relied on him so
heavily ended up falling apart
society cannot and should not depend on
one man alone
and that is a lesson that deku needs to
learn oh by the way how awesome was
ochoko
in this chapter she was willing to stand
up to the school administration
to the pro heroes and even to deku
himself in order to protect
him she might as well have said deku if
you die then you can't become my husband
yubaka
i definitely enjoyed seeing ochako's
assertiveness in this chapter
and i'm really curious to see how this
confrontation between her and deku will
turn out
but let me know what you guys think is
deku going to actually try to force his
way
past his friends or is he finally going
to come to his senses
and work together with them don't forget
to share your thoughts down in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content right
here on the channel
just leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps
a lot and if you're new to anime pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying it's an extra
step but if you don't do that then
you're still going to miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to
alpha sigma he is an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
al-jatal hirokomi and water the toasted
chi the spike
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkus baked buddhist cody
hebert and
monkey d quilly finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven angel crews ratheora
very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joanne garcia
techno ted fatboy games corey mcgowan
and solray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you